[Applaudissements]
voilà alors c'est vrai que ça c'est non
non non c'est s'attaquer aux condamnés
aussitôt sur les réseaux sociaux bien
sûr appelant au boycott du rappeur la
fondation 30 millions d'amis amènera
annoncé sur twitter avoir effectué un
signalement à la plateforme pharos
porter plainte pour maltraitance animale
et demandé la mise en sécurité de
l'animal cassis pas alors non mais ya
rien à dire à part que ça n'avait pas
bien demeurer moi cette vidéo elle brise
le coeur j'avais même pas la voir à quel
moment même si t'as bu même si t'as fumé
j'en sais rien si t'es pas dans son état
normal à quel moment tu te dis que tu
vas frappé ton chien veut violemment au
crâne comme ça que tu va filmer mais il
est tu vas le poster la vidéo la gamme
est encore plus facteurs aggravants
quand tu es censé être un modèle pour
les jeunes c'est très grave j'espère
qu'il aura de vraies sanctions et pas
des travaux d'intérêt général pour moi
ça mérite la prison ça c'est horrible
alors ils risquent irait jusqu'à trois
ans d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros
d'amendé mais c'est surtout qu'il ne
regrette pas parce qu'il m'est fait une
deuxième vidéo où il dit en fait
en dix ans il se sent qu'à sion regardez
qu'est ce c'est sans évoquer un animal
c'est pas lui taper dessus c'est pas ça
l'éducation d'un animal
non c'est honteux si en plus on voit il
a montré les pipis mais il engueule
visiblement pas ce qu'il a fait pipi les
chiens mais c'est de sa faute s'il a
fait pipi de chat un chien bien élevé et
fait pas pipi à la maison donc c'est lui
qui est en tort et cette image sont
ignobles et je crois qu'elle est au
poste déjà ce soir déjà au poste à deux
coups sûrs avec chaque fois qu'elle
chante et nous mêmes ouais 6 6 1
non mais c'est vrai mais je vois là je
me suis parfois voilà je passe le voit
des flammes
je continue ma route et je fais comme si
je n'avais rien à faire je perdais ce
dont il faut se féliciter vous l'avez
abordé c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
faites ça immédiatement les réseaux
sociaux s'en empare vous êtes signal est
très impatient de laylat aimé parce
qu'il a filmés oui mais pas rétrécir
comme le footballeur kodjo lakers ou
moins tout de suite s'est signalée et
quelques heures après il ya une plainte
qui est déposée par 30 millions d'amis
il est en garde à vue et il y aura des
sanctions avant il n'y avait pas ça donc
il faut se féliciter de la mobilisation
générale lui la loi contre la
maltraitance animale et maintenant ça va
très vite voila voila je n'ai l'instant
le chien lui a été retiré
oui en fait il y avait deux chiens donc
celui-là a été retiré et l'autre chien
aussi a été retiré et donc 31 d'amis à
porter plaintes pour sévices graves et
actes de cruauté donc ça ça va jusqu'à
60 mille euros à cela et en plus ils ont
mis plus diffusion relatives aux actes
de sévices donc ça ça pourrait faire
parce qu'intégrer film et en plus c'est
ça
et est en fait ce qui est très important
de dire c'est que lorsque vous voyez ça
chez un voisin sécher un voile il faut
signaler les choses et 30 millions
d'amis ils sont vraiment ouvert il ya un
mail que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet et pour les contacter en fait
je suis assez bon c'est très très
important - heures 30 millions d'amis et
jusqu'au pas tranché sur le chien ont
fait pipi c'est ce qui les a pas sortie
est encore fait c'est non mais ça c'est
lâche c'est assez comme moi ils parfois
j'ai séjourné en plateau si
c'est la rivière de leur enfance heures